hello to all my name is stéphane de
chars whose position is fine
[Music]
I remove this where you must first
take pictures my name and damien vie I am
head of the trade and technologies unit
[Music]
the other subject on which we are
developing the toolbox are
these instruments which relate to
the articulation between trade
and investment on the one hand and
security issues on the other,
particularly in the field of
technologies.  Europe is equipping itself with
instruments it has recently adopted two
instruments it has equipped itself
with a mechanism for cooperation and
coordination on the screening of
foreign direct investments
and it has also equipped itself with a
revised and increased regulatory framework on  the
question of export control, in
particular the control of exports
of dual-use goods, that is to
say goods which have
both a civilian dimension and a military
or security dimension
[Music]
the control of exp  ortations due to the I
'm going to use this word it's a it's a
mechanism that connects which seek to
reconcile in fact security and
trade there are certain products
certain technologies in particular
high technologies
whose trade presents a certain
number of risks  for international security
or for
human rights and which should therefore be
controlled and dual
technology or dual-
use technologies is a fairly large set
of software products and technology
in the intangible sense  of the term
including, moreover, research
technology transfer in research
falls within the scope of this definition
is therefore these are products which
concern different sectors it goes from
the chemical products sector
biology pharmaceuticals energy in
particular  with nuclear, space,
aerospace, of course, security
and the fields of security and
defense against  exports these
are not sanctions this is a
risk management tool important risk
concerning international security and
these are not this is not a
discriminatory tool this is not a tool
that aims to punish certain states or
certain entities a
typical export involves coordinated control
between different member states is this
one of the essential elements of the
European regulations which aim
to coordinate the competent authorities
in the different states are lacking
so that the control is
effective
[Music]
still provides an internal network
of experts and a network of national authorities
who control foreign investments
in the European Union to
see if they have an impact on our
security on our public order on
the essential organization of our states
in  the european union the control that
existed for about 30 years is
a control why protect
effective competition  f to protect the
markets which function relatively
well the control that we carry out in
network with the national authorities
I would be tempted to say that it has nothing to
do the logic is fundamentally
different and we are not there to
protect an asset from an acquisition
which do not pose any risk
to our security and our colleagues from
the dg competition checks whether the same
acquisition eventually it it can
happen will reduce competition will
create a dominant position the two
logics are different a
market logic the security logics
we look at each other  if the target is critical
for security
in the broad sense it is because I have
explained them and we are looking at whether the acquirer
not simply maximizing his profit
can be a risk for our security
[Music]
I would say that security issues
can  be visualized as
concentric circles at best you have
military security then
more security  physical there
police force gendarmerie fire services
then you have questions of
security of supply for example
of energy following you will have questions
of security related to inputs ian to the
important infrastructures of transport
of telecoms and then angle encompassing all
that j  I have read in front
of public order issues, for example issues
of protecting our public health,
you will have member states where
certain companies have a
very important position in laboratories
for testing, for example, or for
the production of certain drugs
[  Music]
milliman germany notification boot
in any case
this
news contact point basterds de
target
[Music
] almost all foreign investment
in the union poses no
problem it's a bit like ideal at
the entrance to an airport you  see
people passing is well over 80-95%
of passengers
no problem no problem  me it's a bit
the same for foreign investment
the vast majority of
foreign investment does not raise
any security problems
[Music]
it